we hopefully know at this point what a
differential equation is so now let's
try to solve some and this first class
of differential equations I'll introduce
you to they're called separable
equations and I think what you'll find
is that we're not learning really
anything you using just your your first
year calculus derivative and integrating
skills you can solve a separable
equation and the reason why they're
called separable is because you can
actually separate the x and y terms and
integrate them separately to get the
solution of the differential equation so
let's separable separable equations so
let's do a couple and I think you'll get
the point these often are really more of
exercises in algebra than anything else
so the first separable differential
equation is dy over DX is equal to x
squared over one minus y squared and
actually this is a good time to just
review our terminology so first of all
what is the order of this differential
equation well the highest derivative in
it is just the first derivative so the
order is equal to 1 so it's order first
order it's Ordinary because we only have
a regular derivative no partial
derivatives here and then is this linear
or nonlinear well at first you say oh
well you know this looks linear I'm not
multiplying the derivative times
anything else but if you if you look
carefully something interesting is going
on first of all you have a Y squared and
Y is the dependent variable Y is a
function of X so to have the Y squared
that makes it nonlinear and even if this
was a Y if you were to actually multiply
both sides of this equation times 1
minus y and get it in the form that I
showed you in the previous equation you
would have 1 minus y squared actually
this is actually the first step of what
we have to do anyway so I'll write it
down 1 minus so if I'm just multiplying
both sides equation times 1 minus y
squared you get 1 minus y squared times
dy/dx is equal to x squared and then you
immediately see that you're actually
even if this wasn't a squared here you'd
be multiplying the Y times dy DX and
that also makes it nonlinear because
you're multiplying the dependent
variable times it
Vivat of of itself so that also makes
this a nonlinear equation but anyway
let's get back to solving this so this
was the first step I'm I just multiplied
the both sides by 1 minus y squared and
the real end goal is just to separate
the Y's and the X's and then integrate
both sides so I'm almost there
so now what I want to do is I want to
multiply both sides of this equation
times DX so I have a DX here and get rid
of this DX there we go here and I want
to waste too much space so you get 1
minus y squared dy is equal to x squared
DX I have separated the x and y
variables and the differentials right
all I did is I multiplied both sides of
this equation times DX to get here all
right now I can just integrate both
sides so let's do that so whatever you
do to one side of the equation you have
to do the other that's true with regular
equations or differential equations so
we're going to integrate both sides so
what's the integral of this expression
with respect to Y let's see the integral
of 1 is y the integral of y-squared
well that's minus y to the third over 3
and well I'll write the plus C here just
just to kind of show you something but
you really don't have to write a plus C
on both sides I'll call that plus the
constant due to Y the Y integration
you'll never see this in a calculus
class but I just want to make a point
here is equal to I just want to show you
this our plus C's never disappeared from
when we were taking our traditional anti
derivatives and what's the derivative of
this well that's it's X to the third
over 3 X to the third over 3 this is
also going to have a plus C a plus C due
to the X variable now the reason why I
did this magenta one in magenta and I
like labeled it like that is because you
really just have to write a plus C on
one side of the equation and if that
doesn't make a lot of sense let's
subtract this C from both sides and we
get Y minus let me scroll down a little
bit why my Y looks like a G y minus y to
the 3rd
over three is equal to X to the third
over 3 plus the constant when we took
the antiderivative of the X minus the
constant of the antiderivative we took
the Y but these two constants they're
just common I mean we don't know what
they are they're arbitrary constants so
we could just write a general C here so
you could have just you have to have a
constant but it doesn't have to be on
both sides of this equation because
they're arbitrary C X minus C Y well
that's still just another constant and
then if we want to simplify this
equation more we can multiply both sides
of this by 3 just to make it look nicer
and you get 3y minus y to the third is
equal to X to the third plus well I
could write 3c here but once again C is
an arbitrary constant right so 3 times
an arbitrary constant that's just
another arbitrary constant so I'll write
the C there and there you have it we
have solved this differential equation
although it is in it's in implicit form
right now and it's fairly hard to get it
out of implicit form we could put the C
on one side so you could the solution
could be 3y minus y to the third minus X
to the third is equal to C some people
might like that a little bit better but
that's the solution and notice the
solution just like when you take an
antiderivative the solution is a class
of implicit functions in this case and
why is it a class because we have that
constant there depending on what number
you pick there it will be another
solution
but any constant there will satisfy the
original differential equation which was
up here this was your original
differential equation and if you want to
solve for that constant someone has to
give you an initial condition someone
has to say well when X is you know when
X is 2 y is 3 and then you could solve
for C anyway let's do another one that
gives us an initial condition so this
one's a little bit I don't want to I'll
start over
clear image invert
so I have optimal space so this one is
the first derivative of Y with respect
to X is equal to 3x squared plus 4x plus
2 over 2 times y minus 1 this is a
parenthesis not an absolute value and
they give us initial conditions
they say that Y of 0 is equal to
negative 1 so once we solve this
differential equations and this is a
separable differential equation then we
could use this initial condition when x
is 0 Y is 1 to figure out the constant
so let's first separate this equation so
let's multiply both sides by 2 times y
minus 1 and you get 2 times y minus 1
times dy/dx is equal to 3x squared plus
4x plus 2 multiply both sides times DX
this is really just an exercise in
algebra you get and I could multiply
this one out to you get 2y minus 2
that's just this dy I multiply both
sides times DX so that equals 3x squared
plus 4x plus 2 DX I have separated the
equations I've separated the the
independent from the dependent variable
and the relative differentials and so
now I can integrate and I can integrate
in magenta I can integrate what's the
antiderivative of this expression with
respect to Y well this is C it's y
squared minus 2y I want to write the
plus C I'll just do it on the right hand
side that is equal to 3x squared well
the antiderivative enter is 2x squared
plus 2x plus C and that C kind of takes
care of the constant for both sides of
the equation and hopefully you
understand why from the last example but
we can solve for C using the initial
condition y of 0 is equal to negative 1
so let's see when X is zero Y is
negative one so let's put Y is negative
one so we get negative one squared minus
two times negative one right that's the
value of y is equal to it is equal to
when X is equal to zero so when X is
equal to zero that's zero to the third
plus two times zero squared plus two
times zero plus C so this is fairly
straightforward all of these this is
this is all zero this is a C negative
one squared that's 1 minus 2 times minus
1 that's plus 2 is equal to C and we get
C is equal to 3 so the implicit exact
solution the solution of our
differential equation remember now it's
not a class because we got it and we got
we they gave us an initial condition is
y squared minus 2y is equal to X to the
third plus 2x squared plus 2x plus 3 we
figured out that's what C was and
actually if you want you could write
this in an explicit form by completing
the square this is just algebra at this
point you're done this is an implicit
form if you wanted to make it explicit
you could add 1 to both sides I'm just
completing the square here so Y squared
minus 2y plus 1 if I add one of that
side have to add one to this side so
becomes X to the third plus 2x squared
plus 2x plus 4 I just added one to both
sides equation why did I do that because
I wanted this side to be a perfect
square in terms of Y then I could write
rewrite this side as Y minus 1 squared
is equal to X to the third plus 2x
squared plus 2x plus 4 then I could say
Y minus 1 is equal to the plus or minus
square root of x to the third plus 2x
squared plus 2x plus 4 I can add 1 to
both sides and I get Y is equal to 1
plus or minus the square root of x to
the third plus 2x squared plus 2x
plus four and it has plus or minus here
and if we have to pick one of the two we
would go back to the initial condition
the initial condition right well our
initial condition our initial condition
is told us that Y of zero is equal to
negative one so if we put 0 here for X
we get Y is equal to 1 plus or minus 0
plus 4 so 1 plus or minus 4 so if Y is
going to be equal to negative 1 so we
get Y is equal to 1 plus or minus sorry
- if this is going to be equal to
negative 1 then we have then this has to
be 1 minus 2 so the core the explicit
form that satisfies our initial
condition we're getting a little geeky
here you could get rid of the plus it's
1 minus this whole thing that's what
satisfies our initial condition and you
could figure out where it's satisfied
because in order for this what what over
what domain is it satisfied well that's
satisfied when this term is positive is
this becomes negative and you get its
undefined in reals and all of that but
anyway I've run out of time see you in
the next video